all right in the wake of the John Bolton
manuscript leaked the media have been
salivating over the prospect of major
GOP defections in the Senate the four
I'm talking about of course are Mitt
Romney Susan Collins Lamar Alexander and
Lisa Murkowski Mitt Romney and Susan
Collins they seem to want witnesses
while Lamar Alexander and Lisa Murkowski
have expressed at least an openness to
the idea John Bolton and Mitt Romney go
way back jump Alton Lamar Alexander go
way back I got to think that those mean
something in this current context well
things really hit a fever pitch after
this headline dropped yesterday
reporting the Mitch McConnell didn't
have the votes to block witnesses from
the impeachment trial Mitch McConnell
doesn't have the votes to block
witnesses which she's desperate to do
this blockbuster news that Mitch
McConnell is crying at least for now
Uncle McConnell has made it clear that
votes to block witnesses aren't locked
in yet he knows he needs a lot of help
now to get those votes speaking of
someone who needs a lot of help well but
as we told you last night the media got
way ahead of itself suffering again from
wishful thinking syndrome it not only
looks like McConnell has the votes to
end the charade he may even have a few
to spare many vulnerable Republicans at
this time instead of trying to move to
the center they're actually privately
telling the majority leader we want this
done and they want this trial over with
so you have their entire Republican
Party to Willys important point
embracing trumpism at this critical
moment just months before the election
well fence sitters Cory Gardner and Pat
Toomey they announced they opposed
calling more witnesses and Lisa
Murkowski may be joining them the hill
is reporting that it was clear to Senate
Republicans on Wednesday after a morning
meeting between Senate Majority Leader
McConnell and Senator Murkowski that the
question of having additional witnesses
is settled and the Senate will vote
Friday to wrap up the impeachment trial
of President Trump
so without Markowski Democrats can't get
the four votes they need to compel
Bolton's testimony
sorry mitt but at least you have gray
hair now despite all the early
predictions that Republicans were
fracturing the Democrats are actually
the ones who are falling apart several
red state Democrats are not ruling out
the possibility of clearing president
Trump on the ultimate vote Democratic
senators from states that Trump won have
not ruled out voting to acquit him
Jones mansion cinema could be squishy on
some aspects of this and should the
Senate vote to hear witnesses at least
one democrat joe Manchin may be Adam
shifting away from his party he's hunter
Biden a relevant witness senator you
know I think so I really do
would you vote to call hunter Biden as a
witness if the judge or whoever rules
that its partner absolutely if the
Democrats called two witnesses shouldn't
Republicans have a right to call two or
four and four whatever they agree on
George Jetson
well faced with a bipartisan acquittal
of Trump Democrats in the media are
resorting to desperate eleventh-hour
shenanigans here's the latest fake news
from CNN's Jake Tapper the White House
has issued a formal threat to ambassador
Bolton and his associates behind this
they're trying to keep him from
publishing the book Oh Jake the formal
threat is in reality a routine letter
from an NSC lawyer that was sent over a
week ago in which he wrote that the NSC
wants to quote work with you to ensure
Bolton's ability to tell his story
without though disclosing classified
information does that really sound
threatening to you oh and there's this
tiny detail the letter was sent three
days before the New York Times reported
on Bolton's book manuscript you see what
this is all going and then came the next
shiny object from congressman Elliot
angle how bizarre who claims it on a
September 23rd call this is just coming
up now ambassador Bolton suggested to me
unprompted that the committee look into
the recall of ambassador Murray
Ivanovich he strongly implied that
something improper had occurred around
her
as our top diplomat diplomat in Kiev not
only is this a really sketchy claim it's
completely irrelevant to impeachment
they got a dangle the object Trump has
the power to remove an ambassador for
any reason they serve at the president's
pleasure and as cracks spread through
the Democrat ranks we predict that
they're gonna try to pull other rabbits
out of their hat but at this point
Republican senators should know how this
game is played just when you think you
see the light at the end of the tunnel
the resistance throw shade reports of
new witnesses flood Twitter targeted
leaks dominate the news cycle anything
to prolong the drama every day there is
new information coming to light we know
there's going to be new information
coming to light on March 17th when the
Bolton books Nook comes out there are
going to continue to be revelations and
members of this body of both sides of
the aisle are going to have to answer a
question each time it does why didn't
you want to know that when it would have
helped inform your decision has an axe
to grind and books to sell nothing he
has to say as I said last night changes
the underlying facts that we have
painstakingly laid out for you over the
past four months now Ukraine got its aid
without ever having to do or say
anything about Purisima or the Biden's
and the president was well within his
rights to be concerned about Ukrainian
corruption in 2016 and perhaps more
corruption coming down the pike in 2020
our founders didn't want us to do
impeachment by shiny objects and the
Senate shouldn't torture the nation any
longer with this tedious faux legal
drama yet just as they tried in the
Cavanaugh fight by digging up supposed
victims and late in the game
unverifiable allegations Democrats think
time is on their side but Republicans
fought this then and they need to fight
it now the only response to the Democrat
sleazy tactics is unwavering GOP unity
at least for a couple more days
and when Schiff and Schumer accuse you
of a cover-up throw it right back in
their faces
they've been covering for their own deep
state for their own foreign policy and
domestic policy failures since Trump
announced he was running and in the end
what will the Democrats have really
accomplished in this shiny object
impeachment President Trump is enjoying
his best approval rating in three years
and that's the angle